so i know i've limited time let me jump
right on in
uh i want to ask you at least one thing
you haven't been asked so
um what tv series would you love to
guest write and direct
oh man i i can tell you right now um
uh money heist i'd have to speak spanish
i'd have to there's a lot of stuff i'd
have to figure out but that show
man oh man is it good it's just a you
know
i was shocked at how much i you know i
didn't know much about it and i
i watched them all straight through yeah
i i know how popular it is especially
around the world
yeah yeah um jumping into uh
specifically your film i want to start
with congratulations
uh uh sincerely um uh
this had to have been a challenging edit
because you're dealing with two
different story lines
in dramatically different situations i'm
curious what did you learn from any
early
friends and family screenings that
impacted the finished film
um well mostly you learn how to break it
up a little bit more you know
at times you'll be weighted in one place
and not in another
the other thing was we cut a bunch of
scenes that
scenes i actually liked and they they
worked really well but
they just didn't further the story and
you know when you get into
a film that's kind of a meditation you
know it's
we're letting the music kind of carry us
um
you have to be judicious with the scenes
otherwise it feels really long and
plotting
so uh so you end up cutting scenes that
you like a lot
but scenes that that you also know don't
further the story so
you learned that from friends and family
screenings can i ask how long was your
first cut compared to the finished film
two hours and 20 was the first cut and
this one's under two hours so
you know one of the things that i find
fascinating about netflix is they have
all this technology
but they rarely release any deleted
scenes on
netflix and they really don't and like
for people that are going to
enjoy this movie and want to see some of
the scenes you're talking about
have you had any conversations about
putting some of these deleted scenes no
i didn't know they didn't
the the effects guys did a really funny
bit that i hope they'll
will get released too which is they take
my character matt kowalski in gravity
and i'm floating still in space and then
i float by ether the the spaceship and
i'm like little help
you know and i go by them which is
absolutely fantastic so
i didn't know they didn't hopefully they
will well i mean
and by the way if you don't release that
on netflix maybe you put that out on
like instagram or something and let
people
that's a good bit to promote the movie
well you know i'm not on any of those
things so that i don't get
fired later in life you know right uh
i completely understand uh what do i
need to do
as someone who really loves you in front
of the camera
what do i need to do to get you to act
more
well you know it's fun it's been an
interesting thing you know i got
twins and they're young and i was doing
a lot of that and
i've been working a lot with our
foundation on chasing down some war
criminals and that's been exciting
um you know i did catch 22 which was a
year and a half and it did a small part
in that
uh you know i'm i'm always looking for
something
good to act in i'm aging out you know
i'm
you know the things that i you know the
things that i'm able to do now are
different
that's fine so i have to look for parts
that excite me
and uh so you know if i find a good part
i'll do it i've read a couple of scripts
that i like and i'll probably
find something to do at the end of this
year that i'll
go back and act my last question for you
um you've directed i believe
seven films and i'm i'm fascinated by
the editing process because i don't
think people realize
how much a movie like that's the final
rewrite and so
i'm curious with all the films you've
directed have any gone through any
radical changes
in the editing room that maybe you
weren't expecting
well uh confessions the first one i did
you know uh steve marione and i remember
i had uh i had three scenes
that i you know everything we did in
that film was in camera so there are no
visual effects
so if you see sam rockwell on one side
of the set and the remove the camera
across these on the other side said he's
run around in jane's clothes and
you know and everything is done in
camera and i had three
scenes that were spectacularly well done
and uh and i showed it to soderbergh who
hadn't seen the movie yet
and he goes movie's great i love it
you're going to cut those three scenes
and i was like you're
you're stoned dude you're smoking like
some kind of reefer these are the three
best scenes in the movie
and i think three months later after
testing and doing everything else you
realize they don't
further the story and it literally
changed everything and i had to
and i and i cut him out and killed me
but he was right you know he knows
steven's a wonderful editor and he knew
exactly what
what i should have cut out but i it took
me a long time to come to the terms with
it